I can't hear a word you're saying
[Applause]
[Music]
I met you in the time you me you made me
feel so I wasn't home
we danced in the night away we tried too
much I had your hair back when you were
thrown oh then you smiled a fear shorter
for a minute I'm stone-cold sober I
pulled you closer to my chest then you
asked me to stay over I said I already
tortured I think think you should get
some rest
I knew I loved you thing but you never
know cuz I played it cool and I'm scared
let it go I knew I needed you but I'm
never sure but I wanna say with you
you're great known to see
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll wake you up with some breakfast
I'll bring you coffee
kiss on your head I'll take the kids
wave and goodbye
nothing my lucky stars for that night
when you looked over your short term for
a minute I forget the winner all day I
wanna dance with you right now and you
look it's beautiful it's a fern that's
where the nappy tale get better you make
me feel this way somehow I'm so in love
with you and I hope you know stopping
your love is more than worth its weight
in gold
we've come so far my dear look how we've
grown and I wanna live with you children
own to see to see you
[Music]
even when
because you are always I'm gonna love
you too my love's you found I'm promised
to death we part like in novels sorrow
fits all for you not everybody knows
that it's just you would mean to cream
known to see you to save
[Music]
[Applause]
a long way since the first time I played
that song